Chinese police have arrested 12 people
in connection with the series of massive
explosions which killed a hundred and
forty-five people in the city of Tianjin
they include a chairman vice chairman in
three deputy general managers of the
company that had been storing the
chemicals which blew up in August the 12
Sky News has been speaking to ban shoot
ton jack a senior lawyer and chemists at
the center for international
environmental law in Washington we know
that there were there were 700 tons of
sodium cyanide on the facility we also
know that there were numerous other
hazardous substances which were stored
there we know that various organic
substances have been detected following
the explosions these substances are
quite hazardous and in and of themselves
some of them are known neurotoxin some
of them are suspected of having
reproductive abnormalities particularly
when pregnant women are exposed to them
but there's still a great deal that we
don't know we still haven't heard from
the Chinese government exactly what
happened exactly how how much of various
substances that are suspected of being
stored there including ammonium and
potassium nitrates were in fact stored
and how those chemicals came to to be
detonated it's suspected that some
firefighters might have actually
triggered the explosions themselves when
they sprayed water on chemicals that
shouldn't have been extinguished using
water they should have been extinguished
using dry fire extinguishers triggering
what's suspected to be the larger
explosion the second explosion what to
me is truly tragic is that the
government did not have information on
hand either because it wasn't available
or it wasn't accessible that could have
mitigated or even prevented this
disaster it still is not clear the
government still has not provided
information about what it knew at the
time that disaster happened and how that
information flowed to first responders
and communities that were at risk from
from a human rights perspective that is
that is essential information to respect
and protect human rights